two videos ago I told you that when
you're dealing with an exponential
function that when you increase X by a
constant amount that the Y values will
increased by a constant factor when we
increased X from zero to one we
increased Y by a factor of 1.5 we
multiplied 1.5 times 120 to get 180 when
we increased X by 1 again once again y
increased by a factor of 1.5 we
multiplied 1.5 times 180 what I want to
do in this video is to kind of quickly
show you I'm just going from the basic
definition of an exponential function
why this is the case why this works for
exponential functions so let's just
start with the general exponential y is
equal to a times R to the X and let's
look at some X values and then their
corresponding Y values so this is these
are my X values those are my Y values
over there now let's say that X is equal
to let's say let me just pick an
arbitrary number let's say that X is
equal to V I haven't used that variable
yet then what's Y going to be equal to
it's going to be equal to a times R to
the beeth power now let's increase X by
1 this would also work if you increase X
by really just a constant factor but
let's increase it by 1 so we're now
going to look at X is equal to B plus 1
then Y is going to be equal to a times R
to the B plus 1 power let's do it one
more time let's increase X by 1 you get
B plus 2 and now a X sorry now why would
be a times R to the B plus 2 power now
let's see what happens when you take the
ratio of each successive Y terms that
correspond to the X terms when they you
increase X by a constant factor notice
every time we increased X by exactly 1
if this was 0 this is 1 this is 2 if
this is negative 5 this would be
negative 4 this would be negative 3 so
let's see what happens with our Y so
over here
if we look at the factor that why
changed by we could just divide a R to
the B plus one by a R to the B and what
do we get
well you might already recognize you
could use straight-up exponent rules
right here the a is canceled out and
then this is going to be equal to R to
the b plus 1 minus b same base you're
taking the quotient you subtract the
exponents so this is just going to be
equal to R that's just going to be equal
to R let's see what happens when we go
from let me go from here to here once
again take the Y value and when X is
equal to B plus 2 so a R to the B plus 2
divide it by the previous Y value
divided by a R to the B plus 1 these
cancel out and we're left with R to the
B plus 2 R to the B plus 2 minus B minus
B plus 1 which is equal to R to the B
plus 2 minus B minus 1 these cancel out
2 minus 1 once again you're just left
with R so hopefully that satisfies any
curiosity you might have had of why
you're able to use that as the way to
evaluate whether this data was
exponential why we're able to just say
hey let's take this term divided by the
previous term and see what number we get
this term divided by that term and if we
get the same number every time we're
dealing with an exponential function